I remember back in back in my university
days I I have kept my the fact that I
was a youtuber or did YouTube videos
completely secret oh yes a shame because
my roommates found out immediately when
they heard me [ __ ] making anime
screaming because like any time I would
record my my housemates to be like oh we
practicing for a presentation and I was
like yeah I was a practicing for
presentation they believe that they
believe that dude I remember doing like
moaning for like a character came out my
room they were all just outside looking
at me and I was like I see cuz when I
was at uni I was like attending uni from
home like from my parents place so like
I had the privacy yeah yeah yeah so I
have to travel like two hours one way to
like go to uni every day and then two
hours to come back and so like I was
like the only people who heard me was my
sister and my parents and I was like a
question that's all that's all you man
that's all still stuck true to myself as
I was I was a teacher and in my second
year my channel he took off for my I
don't know how my students found out
about me cuz they did and so every time
I went for being Christine said that's
kind of awkward weird being like it's
abroad in Japan coin awkward situation
1200 students shower
isn't it so strange now how we've gone
from that to like at least in Japan all
these young kids wanting to become huge
yeah yeah right like if you ask kids
nowadays they tend to say they want to
be you choose yeah yeah yeah sports
stars like that I'm like why oh why